if you look at a business the chokehold
on the growth of any business is always
the psychology and the skillset of the
leader I'm a believer that talking is
both that you gotta go deep you got to
get people to experience things I think
a belief is a poor substitute for an
experience I figure have to decide
what's most important to you and what
are you doing all this for you're just
doing it for money it's a burnout for
anything need motivation what a Thompson
would believe Mason
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's get your motivation
to attend and get you believing in you
grab a snack and chew in today's lessons
from a man who had 7 fathers growing up
and left home at age 17 because it was
an abusive household to founding
companies that now have over six billion
dollars in revenue and he advises
presidents he's Tony Robbins and here's
my take on his top ten roses success vol
5 also if you want to know what Tony
Robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about how to
build unstoppable confidence check out
my 250 for our confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a 30 second to five-minute
video for free every single morning to
help you build your confidence check out
the link in the description below all of
us have kind of an identity for
ourselves a way of defining ourselves
and human beings don't usually stray
from that so if you consider yourself to
be a conservative person or a shy person
I know the way you move to some extent I
know the facial expressions the gestures
that I use your body and it's all
consistent with the fact that human
beings our strongest Drive is the need
to stay consistent with how we define
ourselves emotion is created by motion
if you want to change the way you feel
if you ever try to do with your head I'm
not being happy your brain goes B s
you're not happy but if you change the
way you move your body radically enough
your voice your face your movement your
biochemistry changes it's not a pump up
it's a true biochemical change focus is
controlled by questions
if you ask a different question
continuously that once continuously you
will get a different answer if you ask a
lousy question he get allows the answer
in a lousy state so he said why does
this always happen to me it doesn't
always happen to you but the brains like
a computer ask it a question you don't
have to come up with an answer
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one change your psychology if you look
at a business the choke hold on the
growth of any business is always the
psychology and the skillset of the
leader and it's 80% psychology and 20%
mechanics meaning so many small
businesses you know the owner might be
an incredible innovator maybe they're
right incredible code maybe they're a
tremendous influencer but they don't
know the economic side of their business
right and they find themselves getting
in trouble because somebody's giving
them financial information after the
fact they don't have true financial
intelligence to make decisions and they
get caught up can you can you give me an
example of a business like that you'd
have to name names no I'll do my own
examples I had several companies early
in my career that we're near bankruptcy
because I would sit down and I would I
knew how to produce products that would
change people's lives I knew how to
market I knew that building teams of
people but what I didn't know was
finance so I'd look and say you know
okay what are we doing it oh you got a
great you know you got a 20% profit you
know you got two million dollars in
profit those days little tiny company
and I've come to the end of the year
there was no cash right I didn't know
that profit is a theory you know and so
just not having that skill or someone
might be really great in finance but
they're not any good in marketing so
sometimes it's a skill problem but 80%
of it you can solve those skills you can
get those skills if you can change your
psychology but when you accept that oh
my god the markets down or oh my god the
economy and are is down when you allow
the environment to control your
psychology you're not gonna win rule
number two find fulfillment also my goal
in the book is really for people to be
happy and more fulfilled because you got
a ton of money and still being miserable
right you know so it's it's really it's
it's like mastering the science of
achievement but also the art of
fulfillment it's about if you're totally
successful you're not fulfilled well
what do you gotta get nothing you know
you made everybody happy but you're
so you know that's the worst thing
you've got that's Robin Williams is a
beautiful man so it's a beautiful man
killed himself right and he shaved
everything most people have a dream I've
had a beautiful family you've made the
whole world laugh hundred million people
loved him but he didn't figure out how
to end the suffering money won't do that
rule number three understand business
most entrepreneurs are artists in their
nature look at three types of
personalities and artists to somebody
that has a tremendous gift a skill and
ability a talent you know like an
athlete you know curries and as in the
end an incredible artist some people
they're their artist sales they can sell
ice to an Eskimo some people it's
writing software they're incredible
we're designing clothes and most
businesses are started by an artist who
says I can do it better but they don't
realize that as you start to try to grow
a business and you're the most talented
employee you have in the beginning and
the cheapest ones right yeah and now you
have to hire other people and you know
they're not going to do as good a job
and it ties people into this negative
effect what I really see is the biggest
mistake that these individuals make is
they don't understand business they get
in because they want to do good work for
their client and most of them as you
know ninety-six percent are gone in ten
years and the four percent that survive
they aren't necessarily profitable I
mean five percent of all businesses ever
craft a million dollars gross and that
profitability gross and you know point
zero zero zero six so it's six one
hundred six out of a hundred thousand
businesses will ever do ten million
gross so I say to people in the business
I never encourage people to get a
business I try to push them away because
it's too hard if you don't have the
internal drive to make it through that
psychologically you're better partnering
with somebody you're better doing
something else I think under a semi
business is the challenge and I always
say that 80% of the chokehold on the
growth of any business is always the
owner the leader and eighty percent of
that is their psychology and 20% of
skills like if you don't on the market
you're in trouble
most most entrepreneurs get
because they don't know how to read
their financials they don't have a cool
I invited you know it's like you can go
on in a plane on a day like today that's
a decent day and you can fly if you're a
pilot with what they call visual flying
world so you can loop it around you need
a flight you get a storm you better be
able to read those intricate sir you're
gonna die and most entrepreneurs don't
gonna read those instruments they look
down and they see profit loss and they
know I made a profit or I'm gonna loss
and they have a beer either write one to
drown out the pain I mean I want to
celebrate right and profit is a theory
as you know accounting is a very special
language unless you understand how to
use accounting to make better decisions
until you learn understand and measure
things in a way that gives you better
decision-making capability then you get
broadsided and you know profitability
you get a lot of profit no cash so I
think not understanding the full aspect
of a business not managing your own
psychology and not knowing your numbers
will be three critical things that I
think sabotage most businesses rule
number four constantly improve yourself
they can't have a standard education and
expect to have an extraordinary life
it's not gonna happen the one
breakthrough for all leaders is constant
never-ending improvement and that means
educating yourself and continuing to
develop even greater emotional mastery
because that's what affects whether you
execute enough the opportunity for self
education is there we have to change our
psychology from I'm gonna do what
everybody else does and I'm mad because
it doesn't work anymore - the reality is
this the greatest time to be alive if
you're growing you're learning you're
educating and you're developing valuable
skills so instead of complaining you
gotta say where are the skill sets
valued in the marketplace and how do I
work harder on myself than anything else
because if I become more valuable then I
will be able to give more do more and
change more when I interviewed Warren
Buffett asks the most important
investment I ever made in his life you
know what he said it was I was thinking
of all the companies they've done you
know he said Tony going to Dale Carnegie
said what he goes because by developing
myself that's the most important
investment those skill sets learning how
to persuade learning how to speak
learning and influence all my ideas
would've died on my lips
if I hadn't be able to influence and I
learned it from that little course the
most valuable thing ever it in my life
he said rule number five
change your pattern
I physically stress my body to extremes
because I've developed a process that
take people and help them change you
know in a weekend but my idea of the
weekend is 50 hours and most people once
set for a three hour movie so you know
then somebody since spent three hundred
million dollars on and I got 12,000
people in a stadium I got back from last
night up in San Jose we had for days and
nights like this and we actually had a
halter on me and a group of researchers
that work with Olympic athletes and I
burned 9,500 calories in one day in nine
hours the battery died before I finished
I had I went 12 hours I did I burned
enough calories for two marathons my
jumps because I'm jumping constantly was
equivalent of two NBA games my lactate
as you all know at one is hard to talk
it was 14 and I was still going strong
at 12 hours so there's some physical
stress because I'm a believer that
talking is bull that you got to go deep
you got to get people to experience
things I think a belief is a poor
substitute for an experience and if I
get someone experience changing
something I can do it a really potent
way where they really feel it then you
know if you do that over again you start
to get someone actually be trained to
get a new result it's not about belief
you know belief is important it's not
about confidence I heard that kind of
description that's never blue it's about
its strategy but if you don't have the
certainty you're not going to execute so
I think I've spent a lifetime
accumulating patterns and our patterns
we all have their patterns and make you
angry patterns and make you sad patterns
make you excited patterns that make you
grateful patterns and health as you well
know so I like all of you who are the
best of what you do I'm massively into
pattern recognition pattern utilization
and pattern creation and those things
help me to create changes that wouldn't
have happened before rule number six my
personal favorite live your mission
balance I was talking to Mary Calvin
Erdos who's the amortisation now she
manages to point six trillion with a T
dollars probably the most influential
woman in the financial world brilliant
woman and I asked her because you know I
was earning fifty of the smartest
financial people on the face of the
earth they said I know you're very
deeply caring my mom and your wife and
how do you bailed on it and she said
Tony
she does I make this money you watch it
but because there is no such thing as
work-life balance there's something
work-life integration and I really
believe that in my soul so in my
companies you know my wife and I we live
our mission together we're 24/7 365
together and we love it because we're
driven by the same things one of my
son's is a partner and several of my
financial businesses one of my other
sons is in the coaching business you
know my daughter's an actress and you
know totally different business but she
cares for people the same way so there's
a common denominator within our family
we're also mission driven that we don't
have to separate the two when your
family's involved involved in your
mission
you're not pulled apart you're pulled
together in the same direction I think
the hard part is so many families have
totally different wives and they come
together when they're exhausted and try
to have a relationship together and I
think that's really hard for people
today I always encourage people to say
listen in in your partnership in life
you want to find somebody who's your
best friend because intimacy and passion
is easy to turn on but friendship is not
and if you have a friend who shares your
values and your mission and if you're
privileged enough to do things together
as a business owner I find that to be
the greatest possibility of that
work-life integration rule number seven
hustle I always tell people I said tell
me tell me in your schedule no go well
you know I go to work and I work 9:00 to
5:00 and I come home I'm exhausted and
so you know what am I gonna start a
business I said well what about the
other eight-hour shift cuz that's what I
did right I had to be able to work from
8:00 to 5:00 in a normal job and then
that start weird as a janitor cuz I work
mile an hour's the middle of the night
but I worked 8:00 to 5:00 and literally
I'd come home I get a bite to eat and
then I'd start my work at 6:00 p.m. 6:30
p.m. and I go from 6:30 to 2:00 a.m. and
I'd get another 78 hours in and that's
how I built everything in the beginning
that's honestly what's required and to
not do that is to cheat yourself because
in the end what we get will never make
us happy I don't care how many stars on
your chart how many Academy Awards how
much money you make what makes us
happiest progress progress equals
happiness if you're not growing you're
dying inside we'll never ate survived
hardships when I was growing up I went
through a really tough childhood
my mom was a beautiful soul but she
abused prescription drugs and alcohol
and because people have different
personalities in that area and she would
I'm the oldest I have younger brother
five younger sister seven years younger
and she bashed my head against the wall
she think I was lying and she pulled
liquid soap down my throat till I threw
up it was pretty brutal but it made me
become a practical psychologist
it made me have to learn what makes
people get crazy get angry get excited
love and I had to learn how to manage
her to protect my brother and sister and
then to some extent myself and so you
know if my mom had been the woman I'd
hope she'd been I wouldn't be the man
I'm proud to be so it all worked out in
a very beautiful way but it made me I
had so much suffering in my life I don't
want any human to suffer and I'm F and
driven to end suffering wherever I can
possibly make a difference I don't want
to sin suffering I want them to
experience the joy and happiness and the
freedom and 11 the opportunity to live
life on their terms but do you have to
fail to be successful yes you have to
have suffering to be successful well you
have to fail I don't know if you have
suffer you know the old phrase you know
pain is part of life suffering is a
choice right well number 9 get
financially free what should we as
business owners and professional
business owners what should we never
give up on well I think I figured to
decide what's most important to you and
what are you doing all this for you're
just doing it for money it's a burn out
for anything so you got to just ask
yourself what you want to give up on is
why'd you get in the business originally
what is it you really want an economic
freedom should be clearly one of those
things to people but pain freedom should
be there also that's why I work with
Dennis they go to business mastery to
make him an owner so think instead to
say you know I really could have
somebody else's some of these taking
over some of these clients the most are
scared to do that initially because I go
that's my income we show them how to
time it so that gradually even up
getting more income from other people
working than yourself then you do your
best work you know it's like the goal is
get ffunny actually free not so you
never work again because you don't have
work and you dry up inside you know it's
like when I was growing up everybody's
like making the money to get rich and
retire so I do that at 26 which is food
oh sure
any amount of money I had I thought was
more than you could spend of course that
was not true but what I learned is it's
really about making it money you don't
ever have to work again and then you
work harder and you enjoy more you know
Steve wins a dear friend of mine don't
you know most of Las Vegas and you any
sweat 74 Peter Guber who's here now I'm
friend of mine on to the Warriors and
Los Angeles Dodgers
you know it's movie companies you know
74 years old works does more today than
what I knew when he was 50 Warren
Buffett 8 what is 84 85 now works harder
today there were more that most people
have to work they do it because it's so
fulfilling but it's different when you
don't have to work and you work then you
have to work in your work it's like a
different being and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is understand the power of
compounding please call from this room
anybody play golf so if I said to you
let's go play golf and by the way I'm a
terrible golfer I never play in truth
the island yx6
eight holes I just got for some fun a
little bit with my wife and friends and
as we're walking along I tell you that
but as we get up to the first hole I say
you know just to make it a little more
interesting why don't we bet a dime a
hole just so there's something on the
line now most people are gonna go no
problem they're gonna go you know see a
shark is he set me up
ten cents oh how many holes are there 18
holes how much I got at risk a buck 80
right okay not a big deal and then I'm
just about to get up there and hit the
first ball and I see them just make it a
little more interesting why don't we
just double it each hole so what would
that be first of all is ten cents the
second hole is 20 cents third hole would
be 40 cents four folds gonna be 80 cents
fitful is gonna be buck sixty six hole
is gonna be 320 now stop how many holes
are there
eighteen so we're one-third the way
through and it's three dollars and 20
cents so in your head you say oh you
know I constantly ten twelve fifteen
bucks if I lose no big deal but if we
continue the math what happens let's
take it out to nine holes and see what
is nine holes get up to nine holes me go
wow I wasn't expecting $25 but we're
only halfway there go ahead flip the
balance eleven twelve
now look what happens here we get to the
13th hole four to nine dollars we went
from down here 25 bucks 400 layer worth
409 how do we go from 25 to 404 holes
power of compounding watch what happens
these last holes 14th or 15th or 16th
17th 18th hole 13100 $7 ok so if you're
a good golfer this is what you'll go do
next for next week when you get home
right
now I've got a really special bonus Tony
Robbins clip on how to know who you are
that I think you're really good enjoy
but before that I want to make sure we
were moving from not just watching video
but into action so it's time for the
three questions and to these questions
by yourself talk about them with a
friend or leave the answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what is your mission question
number two what do you need to improve
in yourself this week to move closer to
your mission happening and question
number three what do you better need to
understand about business and how will
you learn it thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
every one of your readers or viewers if
in this case should really ask themself
the question Who am I am i corps because
we all have different gifts that we can
give and business I think you know other
than love your labor is probably the
most sacred gift you can give any human
being because it's so much of your time
your energy it's the essence of all
you've developed in your life if you
look at it there's three gifts you could
give there's the gift of a specific art
a skillset an ability a talent that you
have and many people are artists they're
not just artists like they paint they
have something that they're just so good
at and then they start a business
because they go you know what I can
design better clothing than the person I
work for I can write better code of
course running a business is more than
just the art of it right and most
businesses are started by an artist and
those businesses you know fail so if you
look at that you'd say if I'm an artist
I'm gonna struggle because I'm gonna
want to do my art a great business
person says it doesn't matter what I
care about I can't fall in love my
product or service I need to fall in
love with my client and I got a
constantly changing to meet their needs
don't fall in love with your product or
service fall in love with your ideal
client that's a different game there's
another type of person who's more of a
manager leader meaning their gift is not
a specific skill set like selling or
creating or something it's managing
people and processes and they love it
right and it's their nature when it's
your nature you tend to get good at it
if you work at it right cuz it's just
who you are you're reinforced for it and
then there's the entrepreneur and
everybody calls himself an entrepreneur
but there are people that are
entrepreneurial and they're
entrepreneurs and an entrepreneur by
nature is different
they love risk they live risk it's like
Steve Wynn's dear friend of mine and he
took him in a cow and I saw this guy
lose 30 no ten million dollar scuse me
in less than 30 minutes and the guy got
up and gave Steve a hug and said all
mister win you're incredible he actually
said would you take a picture and I'm
used to hearing this right so I'm so
sure he goes do you take a picture of me
with mr. Wynn he just lost ten million
dollars from a write that guys
to preneur you lose 10 million I'll just
figure another way earn it again right
it's a different mindset entrepreneurs
in it for the money
right they might be for other things too
but they do want to make money the
artist is not as committed to make you
money they want to make money but they
want to do their art they want to make
that dress they want to write that code
they want to do what they love so if
you're gonna be a sexy successful
businessperson economically you gotta
say Who am I in who do I need if I'm a
great artist I probably need a good
manage a leader as a partner because
they're gonna help me build the
organization and I can still do the art
that people love and I'm gonna just make
sure my art is what they want not just
what I want if I'm gonna grow and scale
Who am I
if I'm a manager leader I might want to
tie in with a great entrepreneur because
there's gonna be something much greater
I could be a part of an own a piece of
potentially if I'm their final mantra
nura I'm looking for great artists cuz
they're gonna be the core of my business
I'm looking great manage your leaders so
you got to know who you are and who you
need altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video